attention all landlords and
there are millions of you and i've got
some news
earlier this month shadow chancellor
john mcdonnell shared a labor policy
idea
the right to buy for tenants in private
rented accommodation
in an effort to make things fairer
you're right
landlords would be forced to sell their
homes to a tenant
at a discount of course if the tenant
wanted to buy it and had been living
there for more than three years
now a part of me understands this
thinking alas
it stops there because from higher rents
and shorter tenancies through to fewer
rental properties not to mention removal
of people's
pension reserves the unintended
consequences of this
are vast and if we want people to have
access to opportunity
whether to earn a home or otherwise then
please
can we start thinking about how to pull
people up and not
keep trying to pull people down
[Music]
i dread the thought of a corbin
government and this is one of the
reasons why because this is a
state-sponsored smash and grab raid
it reeks of bolshevism it's communist
and let's not forget
that john mcdonough the shadow
chancellor is a self-confessed marxist
he's proud the fact he's a marxist
they haven't said what discount it will
be and what he's tapping into
is this idea that all landlords are
peter rachman
that the notorious landlord of the 60s
and 70s
a lot of people who bought properties
under the buy to let a middle-class
people
whose pensions have been completely
ruined first by gordon brown's
measures then by george osborne's
measures so they've invested their life
savings
into small flats they rent them out
often not with managing agents
it's their pension it's their investment
they're good landlords they look after
that property
and i think but what he's trying to do
is he's trying to throw another big
carrot to young people
uh to vote labor and i think it's a
really really sinister policy
i think you're right that we shouldn't
demonize landlords there are loads of
ordinary people who work really hard to
become landlords my issue is not with
them
my issue is with the system that we've
ended up with which is where for a lot
of people
the only way they can actually fund
their old age is by buying buy to let
properties
and it's quite understandable that's
what they've done but the reality for
younger people is
that they can't afford to buy a home
that they end up in short-term
rentals now there are so many
consequences of this for example
we talk about the problems of
integration we have in our society about
loneliness about social exclusion
not being able to settle down in a
community to own a home or to have a
long time protected tenancy
is one of the fundamental reasons we
have social breakdown it has
all kinds of repercussions beyond just
being able to get on the housing ladder
and i think that
i don't think this is a perfect idea but
i do think we need to do something
radical if we're going to make home
ownership
and being able to live it's just such a
basic right to be able to just have a
home
that you can settle down and raise your
children in now a whole generation is
excluded from that and it's a very
serious problem so it's not the fault of
landlords
but something's got to give just about
that up since 1997
uh house prices have gone up in england
by 173
whereas for young adults real incomes
rose by 19
i mean that's the situation we're
currently in and it's not about
i mean you use the phrase uh you
shouldn't drag people down you have to
bring people up
yeah there is a net wealth in the
country if you're going to bring people
up
it's going to involve a certain amount
of pulling people down in order to make
the country fairer that's just
the mass of the situation but you don't
do it like this it is wholly unfair
that presumably some state body decides
what the discount should be
let's say that i own a second property
and they've suddenly decided that my
tenants have the right to buy it
and and by the way what they don't
realize and i spoke to a housing expert
on this is
is that people actually will decide not
to let their properties
they'll effectively board them up and
just wait for them to go up in value as
and when the economy ever comes back
so instead of increasing the housing
stock people just say i'm not gonna let
this happen i'm not gonna let my mum's
old house or my dad's old house and
that's what
that's what the other thing is nick will
sneak they'll sell them if they think a
labor government's coming they'll get
rid of them they'll sell them
and there'll be a glut of properties on
the market and who will buy up those
properties
the dodgy landlords that john mcdonnell
doesn't want it wants marxism
is a marxist policy now i you're right
that we do need to
and you're right of course it's awful i
mean those figures that you just quoted
are horrific
but this is not the way to address it i
assure you this is not the way it should
be somehow
labour government building stretched the
building
yeah that could be a debate for next
week this conservative government has
actually done more than any recent
government
to limit buy to let acquisitions because
the changes in stamp duty have had
real effect and i think i think
the fact that a conservative government
has done this is a recognition that this
is a structural problem in our housing
market but i completely agree this isn't
a substitute
for social housing we need social
housing we need mixed communities we
need
affordable homes not affordable in the
way that for example boris johnson when
he was
mayor of london cast it which was
something like 85 in market value i
forget the exact statistic but
genuinely affordable where it's a ratio
of income that
ordinary people who live in cities like
london or manchester or bristol
you've got to free up the planet you've
got to re you've got to take a coaching
horses through the planning regulations
and for the purpose of doing it you've
got to be happy to have some flats put
in your backyard do you accept that we
need to build more
total housing but that means that means
just set a fire
instead of blaze the planning rates
that's what stops there's lots of
brownfield sites
coming a train to most train stations up
and down the country there's loads of
land all around those trades
build on it but this is for me one of
the challenges with the whole
um carbonomics if we want to call it
that because on the face of it
it sounds sensible like of course people
you know i want people to be able to
have a home that they live in so yeah of
course that's what i said i understand
but then when you actually start
applying some common sentence and
digging underneath the surface and
and you understand the unintended
consequences
because i don't think people are
horrible and they're desperately trying
to do horrible things
but i think that unintended consequences
have just been massively overlooked
you're saying right okay we'll have a
load of people that will do a big
sell-off of all of their buy to let
properties
what's that going to do then to all the
people that have scrimped and saved
and stretched themselves to buy property
when it's up here they're going to
plunge straight into negative equity
and there's just i just i i sit here and
i think it's just not bad there are also
millions of people who can't afford to
buy a home because prices have run so
far away from them
so we have a problem no but we do have a
problem
that the one of the most uh
realistic investments many people can
make is in buy to let property buy
election
the housing market should not be a place
for people to store their wealth and
provide income it's not it's not a
sensible strategy because it's creating
a generation that are completely
excluded not just from home ownership
but from having a long time
i mean i'm i'm i'm well my parents are
both doctors and yet for me the idea of
buying a house is simply out of the
question
really not until i um i don't see that
happening for the next 10 years right
minimum
but how important is it to you to buy a
house
well the idea of having a stable
location that i can live i mean i moved
around a lot as a kid 14 houses by the
time i was 14.
so the idea of having you should pay the
rent and it's not so necessary
but they're two different things though
aren't they having a stable home is one
thing but earning a house is another and
that's what i'm trying to get my head
around
as a for a young person how important is
it to earn your own it's not fully
it's not fully stable if the landlord
has ultimate control over the place
you're living in february
i don't think it's not being critical i
think it bothers you that much see my
generation
you know mum and dad told you don't
don't rent try and get a mortgage
invest get property but i'm not
criticizing you i think it's very
different for guys your age right half
of millennials won't be able to
buy a home until they're 45. right a lot
of people start having a family before
that i would say when you start having
small children having a stable home
children no but i mean teenagers can get
around more easy when you have
when you when you're pregnant or you
have small children you really need a
community you need people around you who
support you who you know
the problem is there's not really
anything in between we don't have
protected tenancies we don't have rent
control so
either you own a home and you can
guarantee you live there or you're at
the mercy of six months notice and then
you have to leave because this is
like and i don't want to make it
personal so if you think this is me
second line then i apologize but
what i don't understand is if you take
your situation you just said your
parents are doctors and you just
described that house prices have gone up
all of this amount over the years so
then i would see a scenario where
parents have got property that they've
probably
um grown grown out of now because kids
are old and fleeing the nest
they've got huge amounts of capital that
they've made in that property
in that scenario i don't understand them
well why wouldn't the parents if they if
they feel it's a priority for their
child to get onto the housing ladder
sell their house downsize take some of
the capital equity that they've
got from their property and give it to
their child to help them onto the market
why should they why should they
stay be doing that job well for starters
not everybody has parents
not everybody owns a house that they can
downsize and then do that for most
people
i mean many parents don't have a house
that their parents are still renting at
this at this point this
it's just not most people don't have
that option talking of the housing
market we must move on now whether you
think he's a champion
of democracy or a pompous pain in the
ass
it's hard to imagine the house of
commons without john burke
in the speaker's chair but after 10
years in the role
politics answer to marmite will hang up
his gown for the last time
on october the 31st and finally give his
vocal cords a well-deserved rest
now love him or loathe him no one can
deny squeaker
berko has an unmatched talent for
managing to silence
squabbling mps with banter of the
highest
let's take a look back at some of his
best bits
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't need any help from anybody
judging from representative position
if you don't like it you're perfectly
entitled to your view
i couldn't give a flying flamingo what
your view is
you need to write out a thousand times
i will behave myself at prime minister's
questions
otter
yes for keeping the house of commons in
john berko you are our straight talker
of the week